all right Mike how does what you're
doing relate to AI safety so AI safety
is a difficult problem
I would split it into three problems the
first is the technical problem of AI
safety and this is what many Institute's
are working on and this is hard
how do you make an agent that is
improving itself in arguably a radical
way that stays predictable and stays
safe hard problem yeah
there's also AI safety as a political
problem how do even if we had a perfect
technical solution how do we make sure
it gets put into effect in a good way
also very hard problem but what Qri is
is looking at is AI safety as a
philosophical problem this question of
what are we even trying to do here and
and so q rise research directly feeds
into this and I think it will help in
two specific ways first of all I think
actually a lot of a lot of danger in the
world comes from nihilism people just
feeling that they don't have anything to
lose that sure why not create some crazy
virus or unsafe AI better to roll the
dice it doesn't matter so if we can
indeed figure out better interventions
for mental health through consciousness
research then presumably we improve the
stakes and improve the odds of of the
world by just giving people hope
essentially but uh I would also say that
there's this problem of global
coordination Ian's AI safety and
everyone's sort of playing their own
game and I think I believe consciousness
research may be able to generate new
shelling points for a global
coordination
new just intuitive things to oh it's
obvious how to make the world better and
the different players in the AI game can
self-organize your own that technical
safety with AI political safety with AI
and then doing the mental health
interventions helping people have a well
robust
mental health so that we don't have them
any more of these oops moments of
nihilism or yeah or aggression yeah this
is very interesting
yeah and it's not a solution but it's
part of the solution
yeah